You're doing really well.
What are you using for bait?
-One of Prue's crusty baps.
-[chuckles]
Yeah, they love it.
I've just switched
to one of Paul's sourdoughs.
It's going to blow
the fishes' mind. [laughs]
Whoo!
-[fish] Ugh. Disgusting.
-Oh, dear.
[both] Welcome
to The Great British Baking Show.
[fish] Ooh, it's over-proved.
[both shushing]
[Noel] Nowâ¦
[Freya] What a genuine nightmare.
â¦the bakers face Bread Weekâ¦
I think I can blag my way through it.
â¦and an irregular Signature.
-We're talking crumb structure.
-Yes.
[Freya] I don't really know
what I'm supposed to be looking at.
I don't know ifâ¦ I don't know. [laughs]
[Noel] A tricky, sticky Technicalâ¦
[Paul] There's a blind panic in this.
â¦and a spectacular milk bread Showstopper.
[George] It's falling.
All under the watchful eyes
of Prue and Paul.
God, it's major anxiety
when he's looking at you, isn't it?
I'm so over Bread Week. [chuckles]
[theme music playing]
[chattering indistinctly]
Shocked that I'm still here.
Terrified for Bread Week.
[Crystelle] Making bread
when Paul Hollywood is in the roomâ¦
[laughs] I'm not looking forward to this.
[George] I find it unnerving
Paul Hollywood staring at me anyway,
so Bread Week is, like, extra, like,
"Oh, God. He's here."
[Giuseppe] I should feel comfortable
because bread and pizza is what I do.
But when I do it at home,
it takes a couple of days,
[chuckling] whereas doing it in a couple
of hours is very challenging.
Bakers, welcome back to the tent
for Bread Week.
Yeah, it's bread week. I'm so excited.
Do you know who else is excited?
Paul Hollywood.
You know Michael Flatley
is Lord of the Dance.
Well, Paul is Lord of the Loaf.
âª Bread, bread, wherever you may be
I am the Lord of the Loaf, said he âª
âª And my arms are naans
And my head's a chapati âª
âª I am the Lord of the Loaf, said he âª
[Noel] For your Signature challenge,
the judges would like you to make
a perfectly baked focaccia.
You can make your focaccia in any style
you like or any flavour you like.
It needs to have a crispy crust and also
an open, irregular crumb structure.
-You have no idea what that means, do you?
-[laughs] Not at all.
You just say what they tell you
to say, don't you?
Yeah.
-[Matt] You have two hours and 45 minutes.
-On your marksâ¦
-Get setâ¦
-Dance!
We're making Italian bread.
It doesn't get more Italian than focaccia.
That's why I feel a lot of pressure on me.
[George] Hopefully, it all comes together.
Or it might be a disaster,
but let's hope that it's not.
[Paul] It's Bread Week,
and for the Signature bake,
we've challenged the bakers
to make a beautiful focaccia.
[Prue] The outside must be crusty,
and the inside has to be soft
with an open crumb
but rather irregular sort of big
and little holes, but quite loose.
The bakers should understand that you need
a lot of water in a focaccia.
If they don't put a lot of water in,
it will be very cake-y.
Done, done, done.
After its second rise,
you have to poke little dimples in it.
And that's where
they can introduce flavours.
Whether it's tomatoes, olives, rosemary,
garlic, it's entirely up to them.
Keep it simple. Stick to what you know
when you don't know nothing. [laughs]
Morning, Giuseppe.
-Good morning. Good morning.
-Hello, Giuseppe.
Tell us all about your focaccia.
My focaccia is called Breakfast in Gaeta
because it reminds me of the breakfast
I used to have in Gaeta, my hometown,
with my grandmother.
These olives have been
flown back from Gaeta,
so they are the ones
that are harvested in my hometown.
And the oil has been made
by my father-in-law.
Sounds lovely.
[Matt] Alongside
his imported olives and olive oil,
Giuseppe's focaccia will include
one other unique ingredient.
In terms of liquid,
I've got a mix of water and milk.
Milk in focaccia.
Is that what your grandmother did?
No, not at all.
My grandmother used to buy her bread.
-[laughter]
-Rather than making it.
[Noel] Another baker sticking
with Italian flavoursâ¦
[Maggie] Ooh! Love olives.
-[laughs]
-â¦is Maggie.
A traditional flavour's traditional
because it was good in the first place.
So I'm staying
with traditional taste throughout this.
[Noel] Sun-dried and cherry tomatoes,
basil, and garlic
will top Maggie's
thyme-flavoured focaccia.
I'm using a strong bread flour
with a bit of yeast, a little bit of salt,
and flavouring with a little bit of thyme.
And that's it, really.
[Noel] While Maggie's
sticking to tradition,
Lizzie is combining
her famously-simple Italian breadâ¦
Put truffle oil in the dough.
[Noel] â¦with a taste of the high lifeâ¦
Race day in Liverpool, in Aintree,
uh, me and me family
drink a lot of champagne
and just eat a lot of carbs.
So it's truffle and garlic confit.
I mean, this is sort of
peasant bread for a prince.
-Yeah, well, I wasn't paying, soâ¦
-[laughter]
-Give me all of it, yeah?
-Bring it on. Bring it on.
[Matt] Her rich truffle focaccia
will be laced with truffle oil,
garlic and rosemary
and topped with rich black truffle.
-Do you like making bread?
-No.
-Why not?
-'Cause it's horrible.
-You don't know what it's thinking, do ya?
-What? Bread? [laughs]
-You don'tâ¦
-[Noel] Don't know what bread's thinking?
-No.
-"Don't eat me."
That's what bread's thinking.
And can you stop putting me in the oven?
[Matt] Going in the reigning
two-time Star Baker's oven
are far more humble British ingredients.
The focaccia is called kipper-caccia.
-A what?
-Kipper-caccia.
Kipper-caccia?
Yes, I thought, when I moved to England,
"What did I like about British cuisine?"
I really like kippers.
[Matt] Jürgen will be hoping
his unusual flavours
of kippers, tarragon and boiled eggs
will help him retain the Star Baker crown.
If you win Star Baker again,
-it's going to be demoralising.
-[both laughing]
They're just going to be like,
"Right, I'm out. I've had enough."
You know, it would get boring.
If you do that, next year,
you'll be standing there instead of Paul.
-You and Prue, the judges.
-I won't comment.
-And then Paul will be doing my job.
-[both laughing]
That would be something, yeah.
[Matt] To achieve the trademark open crumb
Paul and Prue are expectingâ¦
-[Jürgen] Ooh!
-â¦the bakers must wrestle
with a dough that requires more liquid
than most other breads.
You always think
that it is just too wet and sticky,
but in fact, it does come together.
You just have to have faith.
I'm grimacing 'cause my arm's aching.
[Matt] Amanda also has her work cut out
with her meze-style ingredients.
My toppings today are going to be olives,
red peppers, stuffed with garlic,
cream cheese and herbs,
some feta cheese and some garlic as well,
so quite a lot of topping on there.
Bit Mediterranean.
[Matt] Her meze-style focaccia
will feature a lattice
to help arrange
her numerous toppings into neat lines.
[Amanda] I love meze. I love picking.
But you know what they say.
Girls who are pickers wear big knickers.
It's true.
Been kneading for ten minutes
and it feels like an hour.
I think I need to get this
in the proving bowl.
This is just going to go into
the proving drawer for 45 minutes.
About an hour for the first prove.
[oven timers beeping]
[Noel] As the proving beginsâ¦
It's like a symphony of alarms, isn't it?
â¦the bakers can turn their attention
to the all-important flavours.
-[Lizzie] This is some truffle.
-[Chigs] Fancy bugger!
-You got truffle salt as well?
-Yeah.
Oh, that smells delicious.
[Giuseppe] So I'm adding
balsamic vinegar to my onions now,
hoping to drag you back to Italy
with my flavours today.
[Noel] Aiming to cook up a slice
of Mediterranean rivalryâ¦
[George] This is how we do it in Cyprus.
Don't worry about the Italians.
â¦is George.
Topped with onion, parsley,
olives and halloumi cheese,
George's dough will have a hint
of mint and cherry kernel,
but he's opted to go easy
on one key ingredient.
So I didn't use all my water
'cause it just wasn't necessary.
You're freaking me out, Paul.
You're not gonna give me
any indication?
-Nope.
-[Prue] Don't let him freak you out.
-Okay.
-[Paul] I love the sound of flavours.
Yeah. Thank you. Thank you.
Is it too late to add some water?
-Don't ask me. I have no idea.
-Okay.
I'm thinking the dough
needed to be wetter.
I'm going again.
Paul's face didn't look right.
So I'm going to do two.
I'm gonna see how they look.
And I'm gonna go
with which one rises better.
[sniffs] Oh, I smell garlic.
[Rochica] I do want them to taste
the garlic the most,
which I'm sure they will,
because I did when I tried it.
[Matt] Aiming to pack a punch
with her fully-loaded focaccia is Rochica.
I've got tomatoes,
feta with honey and black pepper,
spring onions, red onions and basil.
All spice and roasted garlic
inside the dough.
-There's a lot going on with this one.
-Yeah.
[Matt] Her plentiful toppings
will form a floral design
atop a garlic-packed focaccia.
[Noel] Do you make this at home?
-No?
-Not really, no.
Say yes to the camera.
Do you make this at home?
-Yes, I make it at home.
-All the time.
-And you're Italian, right?
I am, yes.
And you were brought up
by a Giuseppe in Italy?
[laughs]
[grunts]
I think this is better.
I just want it to hurry up.
-Something's bugging me.
-Yeah?
Why is this cupcake all on its own?
-Well, this cupcake's isolatingâ¦
-Is it?
-â¦for four days.
-Yeah?
And it's going to get tested
and join these guys down here.
Oh, lovely.
-If all goes well.
-All goes well.
Bakers, you are halfway through!
Oh, my God.
-[alarm beeping]
-Time to take these out.
I mean, I can see some little bubbles
in the bottom
which, apparently, is a good sign.
[Matt] The bakers must now
carefully shape their dough
before a second prove.
Like a gentle baby.
[Matt] If they knock out too much air nowâ¦
It can be quite stubborn,
so you've got to encourage it to move.
â¦they'll lose
the distinctive focaccia bubbles
formed in the first proveâ¦
My cat does this to me at home.
â¦and end up with tight, dense bread.
I'm adding my onions now.
[Matt] It's also another chance
to pack in more flavourâ¦
Get the garlic, spreading it on.
â¦to win over the judges.
Gonna let it prove now.
Stop trying to stare my bread out.
It's gonna win, it's got no eyes.
God, it's major anxiety
when he's looking at you, isn't it?
Just going to leave this
in here for about 45 minutes.
[timer beeping]
Who knows if this is even right?
Whilst that's proving, I'll carry on
with my toppings and fillings.
[Freya] Just made up
my version of Fajita spice.
Not too spicy
'cause I don't like spicy food.
I love Fajitas.
My family eat Fajitas
every week, like religiously.
[Matt] Freya's fiery family favourites
will be flavouring
her less familiar focaccia bread.
Do you not make bread?
No, I don't make bread.
I think it's a bit of a faff.
-[chuckles]
-You know?
-Tell everyone what you called me earlier.
-[chuckles]
You do look a lot like Where's Wally.
-[Noel] Where's Wally?
-[chuckling]
Yeah, you are giving off that vibe.
-[chuckling] Not in a bad way.
My roasted grapes look all right. [coughs]
[Noel] Rather than tried-and-tested
flavour combinations,
Crystelle has decided to try something
for the very first time.
I once had
roasted grapes on holiday with Feta.
And I really liked the salty
and the sweet combination.
And I thought,
why not do it on some focaccia?
I don't know if Paul thinks it's a thing.
He might not.
Scary stuff, really. [chuckling]
[Noel] Crystelle
is flavouring with walnuts,
feta and roasted grapes
and a topping of fresh fennel.
-[Matt] How's it going?
-[Crystelle] I don't like saying "well,"
'cause I'll only know
when Paul cuts into it
and tells me it's raw, that it's fine.
What about Prue,
or does her word not count?
No, it does. Her words do count a lot.
-To be honest--
-[Matt] You can say what you like.
-She doesn't watch this show. No.
-Does she not?
[Noel] Also taking inspiration
from his favourite holiday flavoursâ¦
Today I am making
a Spanish-inspired focaccia.
â¦is Chigs.
I go to Spain quite a bit
and I love the food.
What's not to like?
Chorizo sausage and cheese.
Amazing combo.
[Noel] His Spanish-styled focaccia
will be based in
a garlic-and-thyme-infused oil
and feature chorizo, manchego cheese
and spicy piquante peppers.
-I'd like to congratulate you.
-Okay?
You are the first person
in the history of this show
-to make invisible bread.
-Oh, wow.
-[Chigs] Want to taste a bit?
-[Matt] Yes, please.
[Chigs] What can you taste?
What would Hollywood say,
[mimicking Paul]
"I couldn't really taste theâ¦ the bread."
[chuckling]
I need it in the oven in eight minutes.
No matter what it is, it's going in.
How long have we got?
[speaking French]
[in English] half hour.
-[chuckling] So sexy!
-Thank you.
[Rochica] Good God!
[George] I want it to hurry up.
It's looking good. It's proven enough.
Waiting around is torturing me right now.
So now,
I'm finally putting my toppings on.
[Matt] If the bakers don't add
the distinctive focaccia dimplesâ¦
[Rochica] You have to press to the bottom.
Don't be scared to get all the way in.
â¦the dough will rise
too quickly in the ovenâ¦
[Maggie] You can just
put random little holes in.
â¦and the toppings
won't stick to the bread.
These are my pride and joy.
They are small bombs of flavour.
[Amanda] I'm doing them
in lines like that.
So if someone
doesn't like feta, you can just avoid.
I'm just spreading it out
so, you know, it's not uneven.
Then I'm gonna bake.
[Crystelle] Come on, be good to me.
Please be good to me.
I'm going in for 18 minutes,
and it should be perfectly done by then.
I'm going to put it on the bottom shelf
and bake it for a bit longer.
I'll do ten minutes on 240
and then turn it down.
Temperature sets the crust.
Time sets the crumb.
-[Noel] You all right?
-[George] I have to redo my dough.
-[Noel] Why?
-It wasn't wet enough.
[Noel] Crazy, this baking.
Too wet, not wet enough.
How long do you have to put it in for?
-Depends how wet it is.
-I know.
[both laugh]
-I meanâ¦ Bread.
-Oh, man!
I would love to prove this a bit longer,
but I'm going in.
This is the time everybody
in Bake Off starts looking in their oven.
At home, I've never looked in my oven.
[Giuseppe] Not thinking
of anything other than the focaccia.
If this tent collapses,
I probably won't notice. [laughs]
[Freya] I don't know
what I should be looking at.
I don't know if itâ¦ I don't know if I'mâ¦
I don't know. [chuckles]
-Should be regular, but open.
-Should be regular.
-Uh, yeah?
-Open.
-We're talking crumb structure.
-Yes.
-This hasn't happened before.
-[chuckles]
What's happened to me? I used to be funny.
[both laughing]
You just have to go with timings.
Timing and a bit of feel.
Just don't want it to brown too much.
Butchers, you have five minutes left.
Did he says butchers?
-Bakers.
-Oh, damn.
Don't panic, don't panic.
[timer beeping]
[groans]
Please let it be all right. There we go!
Okay, that's got a nice crust on it.
[Giuseppe] Looks done.
It looks dark, but it's, like, not huge.
-[timer beeping]
-That's me. Time's up.
Everyone else's is out
and mine's still in.
This is just truffle oil.
I'll give it a few minutes
in the tin and tip it out onto that.
[Crystelle] Bit of fresh fennel going on.
Do you know how long we've got?
Bakers, you have one minute remaining.
-Did he say one minute?
-Yeah.
[groans]
Come on, get out. Get out! [chuckles]
It's just too much stress,
isn't it, really?
Try and get that under there
without ripping it.
-The dreaded flip!
-Come on, go, go, go, yeah!
Bakers, your time is up!
Oh, my mum! [chuckles]
[Matt] Please step away from your bakes.
Crystelle!
-[chuckles]
-Bit childish, but, you know, still cute.
We don't have
big bubbles sticking out also,
but we don't know until we cut into it.
Ay, ay, ay.
[Noel] The bakers'
Signature focaccia breads
now face the judgment of Paul and Prue.
-Hello, George.
-Hello.
[Paul] I know you did the dough again.
-Is this your second or your first?
-Second.
[Paul] It's packed
and I like that in a focaccia.
Sort of busy.
-[Prue] I think that's lovely, George.
-Thank you.
The bake is good. You created a good blend
of flavours all the way through.
You just needed a little bit
more water to open it up a bit more.
But I think you're sort of
85% of the way there.
And you were definitely right
to redo the dough.
Yeah.
[Prue] Looks very attractive.
[Paul] It's gotta be pushed down
till you feel the tray.
-[Maggie] Oh, right.
-That far down.
I like that stretchy soft texture.
It's very soft on the top,
which defeats the object a little bit.
But I do like the flavours.
I love the thyme in there.
Maybe a little bit more mixing.
-But overall, it's a decent focaccia.
-Thank you. [chuckles]
[Paul] This smells great.
The texture's nice.
I get the pepper and the cayenne
in there, little hint of paprika.
It's well baked.
I'm really relieved,
because I thought it was going
to be over-spiced and it's not.
-It's really delicately done.
-Ah, thank you!
[Paul] Love the design on the top
like you've scorched it.
-Wow.
-[Prue] That's all garlic.
-Strong, isn't it?
-Yeah. [laughs]
The texture is okay.
The problem is it's very strong of garlic.
I would have put the garlic on the top,
pushed it in.
In this piece there isn't any,
but loads in this one.
It's about keeping it all regular.
Let's ask the vampire
what you think of that.
Yeah, I can't go near that. [chuckling]
-[Paul] He backs away from it as well.
-[chuckling]
It's overbaked.
Needed to come out five minutes before.
-You put the filling in lines, didn't you?
-Yeah.
[Prue] Think I prefer it scattered
so you get a bit of everything.
If you'd put less flavours,
one of everything in one bite,
then you'd have smashed it.
Thank you.
When you put cheese on like this,
you end up with a dry spot,
and then you're going to have
exposed areas of dough.
And that'll always catch.
So what you've done is over-baked this.
-The flavours are lovely. Really powerful.
-[Chigs] Yeah?
-Great flavours there.
-It's delicious.
It's quite an open structure,
but it needed to be much, much thicker.
That's beautiful, annoyingly thin.
-Okay.
-It needed to be a little bit thicker.
And that was beautiful.
Great flavour combination.
And it's so unusual because it's so fresh.
Highly unusual, but beautiful.
-Well done.
-[Paul] Thank you.
[sighs] Thank you!
[Prue] It looks really nice.
[Paul] It's got a nice top,
it's fairly equal.
You've filled the tin quite nicely.
I think it's lovely. Good flavour,
nice and soft, crisp on the outside.
You could've proved it a little bit longer
just to open it up a little bit more,
but you have an irregular
structure with a crispy top
and a fantastic flavour and colour,
so I can't fault it that much.
-I think it's a great focaccia.
-Ta.
-[Paul] It's slightly over-baked.
-Mmm-hmm.
[Paul] You have a big wet spot
that runs down there along the base.
More proving and less baking.
It's quite tight inside.
It needed more mixing.
It does break pretty easily.
It's more cake-like than bread-like.
Jürgen, I'm not absolutely mad
about the flavours.
I normally love kippers.
I just think it could have been
a little bit better.
It's the sort of focaccia
that I would bake,
-but let's have a look inside, shall we?
-Yes.
It's really nice. It's soft,
and yet it's got the focaccia structure.
[Paul] Shows it's proved correctly.
But the thing that I particularly like,
you haven't gone overboard with flavour.
And made a beautifully light focaccia.
And you get a mouthful
of everything on every bite.
-That's what focaccia is.
-Thank you.
I think it's beautiful. Well done.
[all applauding]
[Prue] Are you all right, Giuseppe?
[laughs]
[Paul] So this is your recipe,
and you must give it to me.
-Thank you very much.
-Thank you.
-[whispers] Well done! Nice!
-Wow.
[both exhale in relief]
[Giuseppe whispering indistinctly]
[Giuseppe] I got a little emotional
because I never thought I would get one.
I was expecting a "but" there,
so you knowâ¦
"But this is wrong.
But you should have done this different."
[Crystelle] I'm quite okay with that.
"Annoyingly thin."
But I don't mind being annoyingly thin.
Considering I started again,
things turned out pretty well.
[Jürgen] This time,
it didn't go 100% well.
Paul and Prue certainly
have high standards.
And having had two Star Bakers,
they're expecting things.
But it's not a tragedy.
[Noel] The Bakers
could practise their focaccia,
but have no idea what awaits them
in the Technical challenge.
Welcome back, bakers.
It's Bread week, so obviously,
Paul's set your Technical challenge today.
Paul, any words of advice?
It's a fairly complicated recipe,
but be careful how you add the filling.
As ever, this task is judged blind.
So Paul and Prue,
if you'd like to leave the tent.
Bye-bye. We will miss you.
For your Technical challenge,
Paul would like you each
to make a batch of 15 olive and cheese
ciabatta breadsticks.
Your ciabatta breadsticks have to have
that classic ciabatta holey texture
with an even distribution
of cheese and olives.
They should be served
alongside a tzatziki dip.
Noel, do you have anything
amusing to say about tzatziki?
Funny you should ask, Matthew,
because I peered into
Prue's dressing room earlier,
and Paul was on his knees,
rubbing tzatziki into Prue's feet
while she was asleep. [chuckles]
-Really?
-Yeah.
Did that happen?
I don't know. How am I supposed to know
what's real life and what's a dream?
Well, what do you think this is?
Is this real or a dream?
This is definitely a nightmare.
Yeah. Yeah, I used to be in films.
Okay. You have two hours.
-On your marksâ¦
-[sing-song] Get setâ¦
Bake!
What a genuine nightmare.
Never made ciabatta,
never made breadsticks.
And never made ciabatta breadsticks.
I think I can blag my way through it.
I think. We will see.
Bread knowledge bomb. [mimics explosion]
[chuckles]
[Paul] So we're looking for
a gorgeous ciabatta stick,
obviously all the same size
and the same colour.
Nice and brown.
Too pale, they'll just flop.
Ciabatta. It's a very soft dough.
Quite tricky to work with.
-You're trying to keep the air in.
-[Paul] Yeah. They gotta be careful.
-[cracking]
-[Prue] Have that ciabatta rip.
[Paul] If you look inside,
you see a beautiful open structure.
-It's full of cheese. It's full of olives.
-Mmm.
Heaven.
Now we have an Italian in the tent.
He will know what ciabatta is,
but is he wise enough
to be able to produce these sticks?
He'll be rather carrying the flag
for his country, won't he? [chuckles]
I've never made ciabatta bread.
So this is gonna be an interesting one.
[Maggie] "Make the dough."
What could be simpler than that?
Six hundred grams of water,
750 grams of flour.
It's 80% hydration, this dough,
so it's gonna be very wet and sticky.
The mix is kind of just
letting it swill about.
Oh, golly gosh,
that cannot be good, can it?
Starting to slapâ¦
As we say a schiaffeggiare,
as we say in Italian.
So when the dough slaps
against the faces of the bowl,
that's a good sign
that it's coming together.
[Freya] And I thought focaccia
was a wet dough.
This is just water.
Number two is, "Add olives,
manchego, onion and coriander."
-Are you a fan of breadsticks?
-[Crystelle] Not really.
Food you only eat
when you're really hungry.
-Am I right?
-Yeah, it's a waste of time.
I completely agree.
This task is a waste of time!
As you were. Carry on.
I'm contemplating
whether to chop the olives
or just to leave them.
I am putting my olives in whole.
I'll go with that, otherwise the whole
olive will be as thick as the breadstick.
I was gonna put it on the bench,
but I feel like it's too sticky.
-Erâ¦
-You all right?
Looks like I'm dealing
with troll bogies, doesn't it?
Who eats a breadstick?
-Who?
-I don't mind a breadstick.
[laughs]
Something wrong with you then.
I'm quite working class,
so I didn't know
what a breadstick was until I was 18.
Uh, number three says, "Prove."
[George] Get in there, you lovely boy.
-I'm going to beâ¦
-[timer beeping]
â¦on the safe side
and only leave them 20 minutes.
It's faster and I need fast.
I'd ideally like to prove for an hour
but I might cut it short.
Surely ciabatta in two hours
is not normal.
[sighs] Bake Off isn't normal, is it?
[chuckling]
-[laughs]
-[Amanda] There he is.
[both laughing]
Bakers, you are halfway through!
-Well done.
-No, I haven't finished.
â¦ooh. Right, now I'm finished.
[chuckling] He might be.
And now, I'm gonna make the tzâ¦
Whatever that thing is.
[George] Tzatziki. If I get this wrong,
I won't be able to set foot
in Cyprus again.
I'm grating cucumbers to drain them.
You don't get taught that in school.
You put a condom on a cucumber in school,
you don't grate them.
[George] Done.
This will mean nothing
if the bread sticks don't turn out.
-There's the onions.
-[Noel] Oh, you forgot the onions.
-Forgot the onions.
-Can't you open that andâ¦ [whooshes]
No, because it's half-proved.
[Noel] What are you going to do,
how're you going to play it?
I'm not going to worry.
[Matt] Judging how long
to leave their dough
for the first prove is critical.
I just think it is not ready.
[Matt] Too short a prove,
and it won't develop
the crucial open structure.
I'm just gonnaâ¦ I'm just gonnaâ¦
I'm just gonna leave myself five minutes.
[Matt] Too long and they risk
running out of time to bake.
I just don't want to rush
this first prove.
Is your mum an amazing cook?
-Uh, my dad is.
-Your dad's an amazing cook.
Mum is more of an amazing eater.
[laughing]
She's the taster.
The truth is, you probably know
more about bread than Paul.
[grunts] That's a bold statement.
I just said that.
[Chigs] Well, that looks decent.
It has risen.
You can see lots of bubbles all around.
"Cut the dough into 15 sticks,
approximately 35 centimetres long,
and place onto three prepared
baking trays."
[George] No, manâ¦
I don't know what I'm doing.
I know they're
supposed to be in stick form,
so that's good, that's in the name.
Approximately 35 centimetres,
which is hella long.
God, it can't be 35.
It's not even gonna fit on the, erâ¦
Oh, the other way, Freya. Sick.
[Amanda] That one's 35. Now. [chuckles]
That's going to be a bit thin.
So don't tell him that one.
Paul and Prue make a bit of an issue
if they think sizes don't match.
I know,
but these are not in a supermarket.
They're in a Greek taverna.
-They won't fall for that.
-[chuckles]
[Giuseppe] I'm hoping that,
by twisting them,
I can keep the ingredients in better.
-[Noel] You all right?
-Yeah.
-Yeah?
-Yeah, I'm learning counting.
-[chuckling] Learning counting?
-Yeah.
It's probably a bit late now.
-[Noel] Do you need this?
-No, you can eat it.
-[dough smacks]
-[gasps]
[both laughing]
Oh, my God!
-Stop it!
-Yeah. [laughs]
Was that you? Jürgen, I didn't know
you had that in you.
[Chigs] Come on. Second prove.
Give 'em as long to prove as possible.
[Lizzie] How do you get 'em in these bags?
Bakers, you are half an hour away
from victory, tragedy or comedy.
Or maybe all three.
I think I'm going to go
for, like, eight more minutes,
and then I'm going
to stick them in the oven.
The proof is very key, but given
the time restriction on this challenge,
ermâ¦
I'll do two 30-minute proofs,
which is very, very little.
So when you're home
and you're proving stuff, what do you do?
Er, read, maybe go for a run.
Wow. You definitely
haven't got children, have you?
-No, hell no.
-[chuckles]
Reading. Let me think, I remember that.
Going for a run.
Hang on.
I'm just going back into the archives.
Oh, yeah, I remember that.
There it is, look, one word. "Bake."
Okay, I'm just going in.
[Giuseppe] It's high temperature, 220.
I'm hoping that twenty minutes is enough.
[Amanda] I'm going to go for 12,
and then I'll have a look halfway
and see how they are.
[sighs]
I'll keep this in for a bit longer.
[Rochica] I haven't shaped them
all at the same time.
So I don't want
to put them all in at the same time.
-[timer beeping]
-I'm gonna do ten minutes at first
and then check them.
It will be what it is.
[Crystelle] Has everyone
put theirs in the oven?
Good. Just me.
I don't know if I'm doing this right,
but I feel like long proof, short bake.
[Freya] Don't even know
how long breadsticks usually take.
I just don't want them to be raw.
Bakers, you have 15 hours left.
-Minutes.
-[in silly accent] Same difference.
Maybe I'll just put them in.
Please be good to me, please.
Okay, that's fine.
We should bake
on a "bread" setting at 220.
[gasps] Oh. Turning it up a little bit.
Okay, so it says, "bread oven, 220."
So I've set my oven to 220 now.
There's no point opening the oven door,
I'm just gonna let cold air in.
They're not cooked yet.
They're not overcooked.
Let's turn the oven up.
They're looking out at me. Olive eyes.
[chuckling]
[Rochica] Take those ones out,
'cause there's like cheese,
I don't want to over-bake them.
How long have we got left?
Bakers, you have five minutes
remaining in this task.
You will then have to end the task.
Once that's happened,
then obviously the task will be over.
And then there'll be some judging and--
-You got four minutes left.
-[laughs]
Should I take them out?
They're still a bit blonde.
Perhaps I should put the grill on.
They take surprisingly long.
So I think it's good I went in when I did.
Come on.
I need to get a wriggle on.
So over Bread Week.
Oh, Giuseppe, yours are browning nicely.
I think that the top tray is done.
So I'm taking this out.
Oh, they look baked. God knows.
I was just so confident
they would bake in 15 minutes.
-Too late.
-Bakers, you have one minute left.
[Freya] "One minute"?
This is just rather wild.
[Rochica] Oh, mine are terrible.
Breadstick Jenga.
That's what everyone
wants to be playing right now.
It's just now or never, really.
-[Giuseppe sighs]
-Where's my scissors?
-[Crystelle] Just tell me I can do it.
-[Lizzie] You have got this right now.
[Giuseppe] Come on, come on, come on.
-[sighs]
-[Crystelle] Come on, come on, come on.
Bakers, your time is up.
Oh God, what a nightmare.
Please bring your bakes to the front
and place them behind your photograph.
Mine are going to be raw. Oh, God.
That is a lot of carbs.
Oh, all right. Paul hates raw things.
Oh God! Nightmare.
[Matt] Paul and Prue are looking
for 18 well-filled ciabatta breadsticks
with an open structure
and a crisp brown crust,
served with an unctuous tzatziki dip.
[scattered laughter]
-There's a few here that look good.
-Hmm.
[Paul] Now theseâ¦
-They're like snakes.
-They're a little bit sad.
Not long enough in the oven.
You want them to be open-structured
and crispy on the outside,
so it's a bit bready, but it tastes good.
They're slightly up and down in shape.
Yeah, they are. Bit irregular.
-Nice tzatziki, though.
-[Prue] That's good stuff.
Mmm. It is. These are better.
The bread's good. It's crispy.
Nice to see the olives whole as well.
They got a bit of a stronger bake.
They need a little bit longer,
but there's a couple good ones.
You've lost a lot of the air
when it's been cut.
-Very odd shape too.
-[Paul] Longer in the oven.
-[Prue] The bread flavour's good.
-And more careful with the stretching.
Now these are too small, and then you get
that rigidity in there as well.
But it needed to be longer.
We're testing for their bread skills.
This almost looks like it's been rolled.
It's quite tight inside,
it's not really open at all.
[Prue] Slightly more colour
and crispness on it.
[Paul] Got no onions in it.
-It misses it actually. It needs it.
-Mmm. Move on to the next one.
Shape-wise, they're good.
It's just the colour. They needed longer.
Does taste good.
-[Paul] Tzatziki's nice.
-[Prue] Mmm.
Moving on, these are all
very pale, and flat.
-[Prue] And raw.
-[Paul] And raw.
-Every one of them.
-[Prue chuckles]
All the cheese has come out here.
Yeah.
There's a blind panic in this.
They haven't been in the oven long enough.
-Either that or the oven wasn't hot--
-Or it wasn't on.
[Prue chuckles]
This one also looks a bit underdone.
I know that it's a rustic dish,
but I'd feel cheated
if I got this one and you got this one.
[Paul] The flavour's nice though.
They need to be a bit more
uniform than that.
[Paul] Now these don't look too bad.
-[Prue] The colour's better.
-That's pretty good.
-[Prue] It's holding its shape.
-You see whole olives all the way through.
Structure's better.
-It's nice though.
-Yeah, they're quite strong.
I like that one.
-Same issue again?
-Underdone.
[Paul] Run out of time.
[breathes deeply]
[chuckling] That smell is so lovely.
-[Paul] You got a bit of, erâ¦
-[Prue] Flour all over me.
[Paul] Over your nose.
-I was kissing it.
-Oh, right.
Kissing it better.
-[Paul] Massively under-baked.
-[Prue] Yeah.
It's a shame. Flavour's all right, though.
Now, theseâ¦ Looks like it's been twisted.
[Prue] It's been twisted a bit, hasn't it?
But that looks quite nice.
[Paul] It's quite effective.
It's got a nice colour.
[crunches]
Delicious. You can taste the crust,
with the caramelization on the outside,
which is key.
Wow. Okay. This will be interesting.
[Noel] Paul and Prue will now rank
the breadsticks from worst to first.
Tenth place is this one.
Rochica. A little bit raw,
and badly shaped, really.
In ninth, we have this one. Whose is this?
What were you thinking?
I was like, long prove, short bake.
-And I was clearly wrong.
-[Paul] Short bake?
I apologize. Yeah.
In eighth place, we've got this one.
-Whose is this?
-Mine.
Maggie, what happened to the onion?
The onions, I forgot to put in.
[Noel] George is seventh.
Chigs comes sixth.
In fifth is Jürgen.
-And Freya takes fourth.
-Me.
In third, we have this one. Whose is this?
Just a little bit longer in the oven,
and you would have been there.
All comes down to the colour.
And in second place, we have this one.
Lizzie, they were absolutely lovely.
Just one or two of them were a bit soft.
In first place, we haveâ¦
It's got a good colour on it,
it's got a nice flavour to it.
And I think they're a pretty good bread.
[all cheering]
An Italian making ciabatta.
Who would have thought it, eh?
Who would have thought it?
First place. Can you believe that? Yeah?
Bread, there are so many things
that can go wrong.
Every time it's a bit of a gamble, really.
You know what you put in.
You never know what you get out.
They've been having some happy tea
or something in the back there.
Off their heads. Think mine's second.
It's definitely a long prove
and a short bake.
Like I was so sure of it.
Erm, and clearly, I was so wrong.
[groans] I'm so rubbish at Technicals.
I just don't understand.
-It's a surprise to me that--
-You're on a baking show. [laughs]
-Yeah, who knew?
-[Noel] Same.
[Matt] Star baker, week one,
star baker, week two,
and he might be looking into the abyss
week three, Jürgen.
I think Jürgen's
in a little bit of trouble.
-But it is all to play for.
-Who really needs to up their game?
-[Paul] Maggie and Rochica.
-[Matt] Right.
[Paul] Chigs-ish.
He's sort of middle, but could float down.
What about Giuseppe,
of course, who's from Italy?
-And who's smashing it.
-[Paul] Well, heâ¦
I think the two challenges
played in his favour.
I never thought I'd see a grown lady
pick up a breadstick and kiss it.
I know. Well, I really love bread.
-[laughter]
-Andâ¦ And I likeâ¦
But that's taking it too far, Prue.
Come on, you must've kissed
-a piece of bread before.
-Come on. You've kissed a bap.
-Never in my life.
-Never kissed a loaf?
-[Paul] No!
-A bap?
-Why? What for?
-[Noel] Muffin?
I bet you've stroked a croissant.
That's different.
-You're dead inside.
-[all laughing]
Bakers, welcome back to the tent
for your Showstopper challenge.
Today, the judges would like you to make
a theme display using milk bread.
Never heard of milk bread.
I never heard of bread
until I just said it.
Your milk bread displays
need to be three-dimensional
and the shape and decoration
need to reflect your chosen theme.
[Matt] The judges would like you
to create a bread that is soft inside,
has a light and tender crust,
and is slightly sweet in flavour.
This is the Showstopper, so, like Prue,
it needs to be visually stunningâ¦
-And right tasty.
-[Noel] You have four and a half hours.
-[Matt] On your marksâ¦
-[sing-song] Get setâ¦
Bake.
Milk bread just means that you replace
the water content in the dough with milk.
[Giuseppe] You do find milk bread
in Italian cuisine as well,
but it's usually very small buns
that they use for party food.
Slightly sweet and filled also
with savoury fillings.
[Paul] The bakers
can choose any theme they wish,
but milk bread is notorious
for being a little bit smooth,
and avoiding those sharp edges,
so they're going to have to think of this.
What are they going to use
inside their dough?
It's entirely up to them.
Double cream as well as milk.
I'm using whole milk,
and I'm also using milk powder.
I think this is a really
exciting challenge.
People don't make milk bread enough.
It's a wonderful loaf.
So I'm excited to see
what they do with it.
If you can turn out focaccia and ciabatta,
you jolly well ought to be able
to turn out a milk loaf.
-Hello, Maggie.
-[Maggie] Good morning.
Tell us about your Showstopper display.
I'm staying with my theme of the beach.
It's going to be an octopus
sitting in a rock pool.
And the flavourâ¦
I'm hoping you've never tried before,
it's actually seaweed.
I've had seaweed bread.
-Have you?
-Yeah.
[laughs] I thought you might've.
[Matt] Six tablespoons of dulse seaweed
will flavour Maggie's rock pool octopus,
which will be decorated with royal icing.
I'm using plain flour.
No extra salt,
because the seaweed is so salty anyway.
And the whole of the liquid
is going to be milk.
Golly.
And today, my mantra is
a bit more concentration, less chatting.
-And seaweed.
-I'll leave you to it.
-Maggie, that might be hard for you.
-[all laughing]
[Matt] And Maggie isn't the only baker
looking to marine life for inspiration.
Maggie, when you were preparing for this,
how many tentacles did you think
an octopus had?
I made it with six legs.
-[chuckles]
-[Amanda] A sexy-pus.
[giggling]
[Matt] Amanda will be showcasing
the natural sweetness
of her milk bread octopus
alongside cinnamon shells
and hermit crabs of coconut crème pat
and mango puree.
[Amanda] I thought of coconut and mango
'cause they're kind of
pina colada flavours.
And when I think of the sea,
I think of holidays.
And they do go well in bread.
[Matt] And Freya is giving
her sea creatures a vegan twist.
[Freya] I'm using soya milk
instead of whole milk,
and then instead of milk powder,
I'm using dry coconut milk powder,
so you don't actually
taste the coconut milk.
But I think it works really well.
[Matt] Freya's seascape will see
a hazelnut praline-filled crab
and marzipan starfish
sat either side of its centrepiece:
a chocolate-filled tear-and-share turtle.
-Oh, very vegan.
-[Freya laughs]
Freya said she could beat me
in an arm wrestle.
-All right, go on, then.
-[Freya] You'll get me in trouble.
Put your elbow on the bench.
-Oh, I'm nervous.
-Right, hook up, you ready?
-Waitâ¦
-[Paul] So when I release, you go.
-[Freya] Butâ¦
-All right? Go.
No! No! No!
-Come on, Freya! Come on, Freya!
-Come on, Freya!
[laughter]
-Oh, there we go.
-[Noel] She beat me.
I can't move my arm now.
-You were too powerful.
-[Prue] I'll take you to the medic.
Jeez.
[Prue] That'll keep him fit.
-[Jürgen] Sorry, sorry.
-[all chuckling]
[Jürgen] Didn't get a workout yesterday.
God, he was doing my nut in
in the practice tent.
What can I do? It's my style. [chuckling]
[Lizzie] I'm kneading mine in the mixer
'cause it's easier.
That's what's happening here.
[Noel] Using the mixer for kneading
can encourage gluten development
in an enriched and wet dough
such as milk bread.
This mixer wants to go places,
it keeps roaming around the bench.
[Noel] But overmixing
can result in a tight, crumbly loaf,
the opposite of what the judges
will expect.
Milk bread is soft, and it's got
a baby-food texture, if you like.
[Noel] Baby food is something
that Jürgen is taking literally.
When we got the brief,
my wife Sophia, my coach,
immediately thought of a baby.
A baby is round, a baby drinks
a lot of milk, a baby is sweet.
Erm, everything the sculpture should be.
And so that's what I'm going to make.
[Matt] A creche of toys
and two milk bottles
filled with chocolate
and vanilla crème mousseline
will surround Jürgen's
playful milk-bread baby
on a polka dot play mat.
-[Prue] We're going to eat a baby?
-Yes. Yeah.
Okay.
Well, you can eat the milk bottle
and the various toys.
Oh, there will be toys around?
-You can leave the baby for Paul.
-Okay.
Paul would love to eat a baby.
[Prue] Okay, baby and toys.
I'm looking forward to seeing this baby
and eating its rattle.
-Great.
-[both laughing]
So it's going to prove
for about 90 minutes,
in order for the yeast to liven up.
It will need a lot of time
to develop the flavour
and to develop the loftiness
that is typical of the milk bread.
I'm not using the proving drawer.
It's warm in here.
Let's have some faith here.
[Matt] While George may be confident
with the prove,
his concerns lie elsewhere.
[George] What worries me the most
is the baking process.
And stacking, 'cause it's kind of
going to be a bit stacked.
[Matt]
Sitting on a cinnamon-flavoured tree
will be his children's favourite animal,
a koala bear, whose legs will be filled
with chocolate and tahini.
[Paul] Have you practised this?
-I have. The first time was horrendous.
-Right.
It ended up looking
like a sunken sea turtle,
or some sort of blob.
The bread's very soft.
When you start stacking it,
anything can happen.
It's all about the shape.
So you just got to be careful
with proving and baking.
[Matt] With multiple doughs to make,
prove and bake
time management is crucial.
[Freya] Probably one of the hardest bits
is being able to stagger
your different bits,
so they're all sort of proved
and baked by the end.
[Matt] And if things weren't already
tricky enoughâ¦
I've got a system of Post-it Notes
going on so I don't get confused.
'Cause that's
what you don't need to be doing.
â¦some of the bakers
have decided to make fillings
to complement the flavour
of their milk bread.
[Jürgen] I'm making my crème mousseline
which is essentially crème pat
with added butter.
I'm doing the lemons
sort of like a craqueline,
which is going to go on my roast potatoes.
[Noel] When it comes
to flavours and fillings,
Crystelle is pushing the gravy boat out.
My milk bread Showstopper,
I'm calling it "Bready for Sunday Roast."
Because for me,
roast dinner is what
brings my family together.
[Noel] Inspired by family roasts
that have continued online
during lockdown,
Crystelle is bringing
a host of flavours to the table.
I've got a lime curd piped in my potatoes.
I've got a carrot cake-inspired filling
for my carrots.
Erm, I've got
a chocolate hazelnut frangipane,
which is going on my Yorkshire pudding.
Oh, Yorkshire puddings.
[LIzzie] This is a honey glaze
for my pig banquet.
[Noel] And Lizzie has traced
the traditional roast
back to its beginnings.
Where I walk my dog, normally,
it's like an old Tudor hall.
So I'm doingâ¦
If you were a Tudor, on your table,
you get a pig and veg around them.
Like that.
[Matt] Lizzie's Tudor hog roast
will be infused with mango tea
from her local tea shop
and have added sweetness
in the form of condensed milk.
-[Paul] That'll be nice and sweet.
-The reason for the condensed milk--
I just liked it better.
Plus, I've been having it in coffee.
-Nice, lovely in coffee.
-[Lizzie] Yes!
Maggie said it's gonna kill me,
that my arteries are gonna be clogged,
but it's worth the risk.
Bakers, you are halfway through!
Okay, what am I doing?
-Eh, do you want a handshake?
-No.
-Sorry, Paul, your fingers are too doughy.
-Hey, hey, come on.
This is proved, I'm happy,
I'm happy with the size.
[Matt] If the first batches
have risen to the occasionâ¦
All right, if that stays, it's ready.
[chuckles] This is a family show, right?
â¦it's time to start shaping the dough,
which is key to achieving the distinctive
themes Paul and Prue are looking for.
[Maggie] It's proved a little faster
than I thought but not much.
So I need eight legs.
It's a tricky dough to shape,
because it's so soft and supple.
You've got to really
accentuate the shapes now,
'cause it's going to lose a lot
in the oven.
[Rochica] So this is
the top of the birdcage.
I need to make sure it keeps its shape.
It's worked three times,
so just need it to work today.
[Matt] Rochica will be hoping her cinnamon
and nutmeg-flavoured milk bread
will hold together to form a bird cage
alongside a cinnamon bird and nest of eggs
based on the birdbath in her nan's garden.
Are you a fan of birds?
-Not really. But my nan is.
-Do you like baking?
-Not right now.
-[both laughing]
-[Matt] Are you learning?
-Yeah, I am learning every day.
I always say about Paul Hollywood,
people come into this tent,
they're really learning
from the fourth or fifth best.
Yeah. [chuckling]
I had a pet pig called Susie.
It died. Didn't eat it.
Right now he's clearly a pig.
He could very much change.
I've had some disasters.
[Matt] Oh, look at the baby.
-[Jürgen] Yes.
-Have you made this at home?
I made this in the practice tent.
Was it authentic?
Did it taste of real baby?
It tasted, uh, sweet
as a real baby tastes, yes.
I knew there was something about this guy.
-I haven't eaten babies.
-No.
Let's get a few suckers on
and then I can get him in the oven.
If the suckers stay on,
the little suckers.
-Wow.
-What do you think it looks like?
Uhâ¦
-Oh, you're going to say somethingâ¦
-Paul naked.
-[both laugh]
-Chicken, of course.
165. We're going low and slow.
Like you'd cook a pig anyway, isn't it?
[Matt] Milk bread needs
a lower temperature than standard bread,
as the lactose in the milk
can cause it to brown
before it's fully baked through.
I'm baking at 170 degrees.
Sweet dough likes lower temperatures
because the sugars burn easily.
[Matt] But if you take it out too soon,
it will flatten,
losing its all-important shape.
They're going in at different times
because I've got different sizes
and I want them to bake evenly.
[Chigs] I'm going to get
the next one ready now.
But making and shaping milk bread.
Two different things.
So I'm trying to just create something
simple but trying to do it well.
[Noel] Inspired by family picnics
as a child in Leicestershire,
Chigs is forming his orange blossom
honey-flavoured milk bread
into a picnic basket
containing bread, fruits and cheeses.
-Is this what goes in the basket?
-There's some apples.
-Yeah.
-And grapes.
-Some bigger grapes.
Yes.
-Swiss cheese.
-Yes.
And then in the proving oven,
I've got someâ¦ Do you mind?
-Some bread rolls, I've made.
-Oh, that's clever.
So what you've done
is you've used bread to make bread rolls.
-Yeah.
-Conceptual.
-Do you like that?
-Yeah.
[Noel] Also filling a basket
full of treats for his family
is Giuseppe.
[Giuseppe] My Showstopper is effectively
a collection of fruit and veg.
We at home use and eat
an inordinate amount of fruit and veg.
I would like to say that we do it
because we want to set
the example to the kids.
We just do it
because we genuinely like it.
[Noel] Giuseppe's fruit and veg
will be flavoured
with the zest of three oranges,
cinnamon and orange extract
and glazed with an orange liqueur
and honey syrup.
Well, someone had
a pretty good day yesterday, didn't they?
-Who was that?
-Who could that be?
Who's that? I don't know. You tell me.
Did you call your family and tell them?
-Indeed. Yes.
-Did you? What did they say?
-Well, my wife was very happy.
-Yeah.
When I told my mum she was like,
"What the hell is Bake Off?"
-Really?
-She has no idea.
I'm going to do a time call,
but I'll do it in the style of Crystelle.
I'm just going to get into character.
Bakers, you have one hour left.
I think that was pretty good.
Right, it's going in now.
[Rochica] So I've just put
the other parts of my birdcage in,
so they're going in for 15 minutes.
This is now becoming a juggling act
because there's so many elements here.
I don't want an under-baked dough,
that would be a disaster.
This is the koala going in now.
And now we wait.
Gonna give it a bit longer.
Oh, God, this is horrible.
Just worrying about him.
Just sick with worry.
-You all right?
-Yeah.
Happy? No problems?
-No problems. Yeah.
-Baby in the oven?
[laughing] This is a conversation I didn't
imagine I would be having with someone.
Coincidentally, it's a bun as well.
I think it can come out.
I'm petrified of it not being cooked,
but also, I want it to be cooked.
I think that they look fine.
Who knows? Who knows?
Just gonna pop this onto the top.
[Matt] With the breads beginning
to come out of the ovenâ¦
These are better shaped
than yesterday's breadsticks.
â¦decoration and assembly can begin.
This bit has been notorious
for going really badly.
The hardest part's
assembling the birdcage.
I've given birth. Uh, fairly happy.
[Lizzie] It's lost its definition.
With shaping bread,
it's all about the definition.
Still looks like a pig.
Once he's glazed and everything.
[Amanda laughs] Be nice with some chips.
[Noel] These are amazing.
-Hello, Neil.
-Neil or Noel?
-Noel.
-[both laugh]
I thought we were close. I'm heartbroken.
-Hello, Noel.
-[laughing]
-You know, my real name's Giuseppe.
-Is it?
[exclaims] Golly gosh.
They're not as shell-like
as I'd like them to be
but they're okay.
I don't know
if they're baked in the middle.
I've got lime curd in here
and I'm just using it
to pipe my roast potatoes.
I'm brushing the top of my crab
with agave nectar,
which is basically
a vegan version of honey.
So I've got the handle
for the basket left in the oven.
Uh, that's going to come out
in a couple of minutes.
Time check, somebody, please.
Bakers, you have ten minutes left.
[whimpers]
Oh, it's all a bit
of a shambles, isn't it, really?
That last hour just goes.
Just adding a bit of isomalt
just to secure it a bit more.
[George] Oh, used the wrong arm.
Doesn't matter.
[Lizzie] My pumpkins are a bit burnt,
but better burnt than underdone.
I wonder if the eyes are higher up.
What does a crab even look like?
They are looking okay,
unless they collapse.
Hopefully theyâ¦ They hold up.
The only thing holding
this koala together is my hands.
It looked fine a second ago.
[Freya] Stupid bread.
Just giving the kid a dummy.
Maybe it's making too much noise.
He's just lost his head. [chuckles]
It's very delicate,
but it's staying up on its own now.
Do a milk display,
why'd you have to stack it?
It's falling.
Still looking like a chicken,
which is good.
[Freya] I feel like Paul's gonna go,
"That's not attached."
Paul can like what he wants,
but he's getting what he's given.
[Rochica] Spent so long trying to fix this
that I left them in the oven too long.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
[Crystelle] Oh, God.
[Maggie] I'm really on it now.
It's a particular breed of mushroom,
this one,
that you can only find
in the Bake Off tent.
I don't know whether there's
any sweetcorn in Tudor banquets
but there is in mine.
Oh. I thought I'd lost an arm.
I would never plate a roast dinner
up like this at home.
Oh, right,
I need to put them on the board.
[Jürgen] Some finishing touches.
[Lizzie] Don't like the way
he's gone all crinkly.
[Giuseppe] Doesn't want to fit anywhere.
Oh, that's hilarious. [laughs]
Oh, my God! Just stay.
Bakers, your time is up.
-All right.
-Please step away from your bakes.
-[sighs heavily]
-[Chigs] Sick, happy, done.
Can I eat this?
Comfort eating. [laughing]
[Giuseppe] We are a good bunch, aren't we?
Look at that octopus.
Everything is so stunning.
[Noel] It's judgment time
for the baker's Showstoppers.
[in Australian accent] Mate,
would you like to bring your koala up?
[all laughing]
-I think he's adorable.
-[Paul] It's simple, but it works.
[Prue] Lovely.
The bread's a bit heavy.
The thing is, when you do
stand-up milk bread sculptures,
the dough is so soft, it will collapse.
-Yeah.
-[Paul] It works on a koala.
'Cause it's quite charming.
But it's concertinaed up
because it can't carry the weight.
But I think the design is clever enough,
and your base oneâ¦
This is nice. It's just sweet enough.
-[Prue] Well done, George.
-Thank you very much.
You've caught a few of them in the oven.
-Yeah.
-But I quite like that.
-Looks like it's been on a barbecue.
-[both laughing]
But the overall design
I think is very clever.
The pig was probably up here,
and it's dropped a bit.
So basically you've got mango tea.
Yeah. I did have a pet pig,
so, it's called, er, Susie.
What happened to Susie?
She slipped on ice,
we had to get her put down.
[all chuckling]
Slipped on ice?
-Yeah.
-Don't take pigs ice-skating.
She was living in the garden,
the ground got icy.
I like the texture. And it is light.
You can get that tea, can't you?
-Not sure whether I like it, but, ermâ¦
-Quite perfumed.
But I can identify it,
that's the key thing.
-Thank you, Lizzie.
-Ta.
It's beautifully done.
[Paul] It's not bad.
It looks quite well-proved.
You can see how round it is.
[Prue] I think that's really well made.
But I don't get
a lot of orange blossom flavour.
You get a hint of something
slightly aromatic at the back.
It's light, it's fluffy.
The textures and colours
are pretty consistent.
-It's a nice bread, that.
-[Prue] Very nice.
Good design.
Simple but highly effective as well.
-Thank you.
-[Prue] Well done, Chigs.
It's quite abstract. Looks quite rustic,
and then this looks quite neat.
Yes.
Is that four and a half hours'
worth of work?
Well, it was for me.
[all laughing]
Good answer.
[continues laughing]
It's under-proved and it's got no flavour.
I'm hard-pushed
to find the seaweed in that.
See, there's simply not enough in it.
The sweetness is there,
but it's very cake-like.
Could be a bit lighter.
But I honestly think
if you put a bit of salt in it,
you'd have the flavour,
because I can get the seaweed.
But there's no doubt
that salt would enhance it.
[Maggie]
Well, that's rather disappointing.
-But never mind.
-[Paul] Yeah, it is.
-Thank you, Maggie.
-Thank you.
[Noel] Well done.
The way you've incorporated
different flavours
in different breads is very clever.
The babyâ¦
[Paul and Prue chuckle]
â¦is very basic,
but it does work, it's effective.
Colour looks great on the bread as well.
You glazed this?
I glazed it with egg wash. Egg wash.
Lovely flavour.
-[Prue] Very good flavour.
-The sweetness level's just right.
But for me, it is slightly under-proved,
and therefore
you haven't got that structure.
So, nearly there.
-[Paul] Thank you, Jürgen.
-Thank you.
It's very clever.
And you've created a theme.
The chicken could have been a bit higher.
-Spatchcock.
-Uh, yeah.
[Prue] It's definitely
a spatchcock or a turtle.
I think your craqueline
could've been a bit darker.
-[Crystelle] Okay.
-[Paul] A bit longer in the oven
would've created more of a darkness to it.
The flavours are great, though.
The citrus kick is fantastic.
The top is beautiful.
The texture is lovely. It's light.
It's got a nice sweetness to it,
which is just right.
-It's really a nice slice of bread.
-Thank you very much.
I think the design is incredible.
You've done an amazing job.
It's actually quite simple,
but you've executed it beautifully.
Paul's never had fruit or veg before.
He only eats bread.
So can you tell us what each one is?
So you've got a courgette--
-He is as well.
-[all laughing]
Apples and mushrooms, yeah.
The texture in there,
it's light, it bounces back.
And the flavour's in there as well.
It's difficult to get orange
to come through in bread,
but you get the zest,
which is a much purer form of orange.
I think you've done
something that's, erm, very clever.
It's absolutely delicious.
And I think the texture's lovely.
-Well done, Giuseppe.
-Thank you.
I think you've done a really good job.
You've lost a lot of definition,
but you've utilized that to your strengths
to make the octopus the way it does.
It's very clever and effective.
I think it's delightful.
You can see how tender the loaf is.
I love that. I love the flavour.
The sweetness is just the right side
of sweetness, and the texture is spot-on.
But it's not bouncy.
You've ended up
with a massive air pocket in there.
But I think it's very good,
very brioche-like.
-It's light, it's well-baked.
-I think you've done a terrific job.
-Well done.
-Thank you so much.
There's something wrong
with the proportions.
That little bird, even if it was upright,
couldn't have laid those eggs
in a million years.
It's over-proved.
You've lost it 'cause it's going flat.
It's a bit tight.
It's under-proved as well.
This is going to prove
at a slightly different level to this.
-[Rochica] Oh, okay.
-[Paul] Because it's smaller pieces.
The cinnamon level's right.
Sweetness level's right as well.
Just that the dough's too dense.
And when you say
that's four and a half hours' work,
I wouldn't believe you.
Erm, that does taste absolutely delicious.
But the texture's not right.
-[Paul] Thank you, Rochica.
-Thank you.
[Prue] I think it's really very amusing.
And I must say that the crab shell
is so realistic.
-It's beautifully done.
-I like it, it's very neat.
Let's have a look.
Is the beach demerara sugar
or soft brown sugar?
Yeah, it's soft brown sugar.
Nice milk bread.
The structure's light, holds its shape.
And the sweetness levels
are just right as well.
-It's not overly sweet.
-It's nicely baked.
Tastes good, and I love the look of it.
I think it's just hilarious.
Aw, thank you so much. [chuckles]
[Freya] I'm so pleased.
I wasn't sure what to expect
coming into this week,
with me not really enjoying bread.
So I'm really thrilled about it. Yeah.
[Maggie] I'm disappointed
that I didn't do better in the bread,
'cause I make bread all the time.
And this is maybe
the last time you see me.
[Rochica] It's definitely been
my worst week.
I would like another chance,
but I don't know if I'm going to get one.
[sighs]
[Matt] So where are we at?
Milk bread's quite difficult
to do properly.
I think most of them
did a pretty good job.
Simplicity was the way forward.
And I think Giuseppe got that.
What Giuseppe has done is clever.
-[Noel] What about Freya?
-[Paul] I would say Freya was up there.
She has done well.
There's a few people
who are sort of middle ground,
and I thought Jürgen saved himself.
-George is--
-Lizzie is doing well.
Lizzie really excelled, I think.
What about Maggie?
-[Paul] Maggie struggled.
-[Prue] I think she's in trouble.
I didn't get the flavours in that.
I thought the structure
wasn't particularly good.
I think it was a little bit too simple.
I think the two people,
I think Maggie and I also think Rochica.
The trouble with Rochica's
is that the whole thing didn't work
because there wasn't
a loaf of bread there,
and we're trying to judge bread.
But I really like them all now.
I don't want anybody to go home.
This is quite a hard point to leave,
because they're just
getting to know each other nowâ¦
-Settled--
-Settling into the life
of the prison camp where we film.
[all chuckling]
To be fair, a lot of them
have tried to escape already.
Well done, bakers. Big week, bread week.
Especially in front
of the breadfather, Paul.
It's a tough one,
but you all did really well.
I've got the great job this week
of announcing who is Star Baker.
The person who's Star Baker this week isâ¦
-Giuseppe.
-[all applauding]
Yeah! Bravo!
Now I have the less fun job of telling you
who's going to be going home,
and it gets harder and harder each week
because we're becoming friends
and we're bonding.
And we don't want to lose anyone.
But I'm afraid
we are going to be losing somebody,
and that person isâ¦
Rochica.
[Freya] It's okay.
[Rochica] It's come to end,
but I have really, really enjoyed it.
And not everybody gets to bake
in the Bake Off tent.
So I'm proud of where I've got to.
And I'm just going to keep baking.
Just don't do anything to,
like, time. [laughs]
-We're gonna miss you.
-I'll miss you too.
-Just getting to know you.
-I know, right?
[Maggie] Your family
will be so happy to see you.
[laughing] I think
I was very close to the edge.
The cliff was crumbling rather badly,
but I seem to have scraped through again.
-Well done, Maggie.
-I don't know how I keep doing it.
-Squeak through.
Next week,
I've got to be spectacular. [snorts]
[Jürgen] Can't win them all.
Can't win all the Star Bakers.
It feels very good to be
at the end of Bread Week and still in.
-[Prue] So deserved, really.
-Thank you.
Star Baker, can you believe that?
Especially for Bread Week.
I better savour it 'cause
it ain't gonna happen again. [laughs]